we're all happy that we are in a new era
you know we get to tell the truth things
are different now
meghan markle's friend janina gavankar
is opening up about the couple's
shocking tell-all interview with
oprah winfrey i will say i don't speak
for them
i speak for myself janina appeared on
this morning on itv wednesday
offering her candid reaction to
buckingham palace's statement
which acknowledged prince harry and
megan's public pain
while also noting that some
recollections may vary
i'm so thankful that they are finally
acknowledging
the experience but on the other side i
know that the family and the staff were
well aware of the extent of it and
though their recollections
may vary ours don't because we lived
through it with them
the 40 year old actress who noted that
she actually watched the special with
prince harry and
meghan added that there are many emails
and texts to support the couple's
recollection of the events
that led to them stepping down as senior
members of the royal family
while they were braced for for something
explosive they totally underestimated
just how far harry and megan would go
and i think they took everyone by
surprise
and when asked who specifically knew
that megan had been suffering from
suicidal thoughts
and had requested and been denied
treatment
janina had this to say i don't know who
knew
i know that the family and the staff
knew janina also addressed former palace
staff members
alleging that megan had bullied them i
have known her for 17 years and i have
seen the way that she regards the people
around her and
and the people she works with and i can
say she's not a bully
but i can also say that i am personally
glad that
people are doing their due diligence
because i also know why
someone had to leave and it was for
gross misconduct
the times newspaper has reported that
the duchess allegedly bullied
two members of her household staff out
of kensington palace
and made the life of the third member of
staff almost unbearable
those are the allegations they are
strongly refuted by the duchess of
sussex who says she didn't bully
anyone out of the palace janina also
shot down claims that megan is trying to
take down the royal family
i don't think the intention was to nuke
them i think it was just
finally a chance to tell their truth you
know megan's always been a very open
person
she's always shared parts of herself in
the way that we always do
but that all changed when she joined the
family
we watched as a wall was built around
her she was very
isolated so how is the couple doing now
that their story
is out there i think they are feeling
free
it's nice to see them feel free
and now they can get back to what
they really were focused on but janina
isn't the only celebrity to come forward
showing their support for megan and
harry
of course on tuesday beyonce posted this
pic with the duchess of sussex on her
website
writing thank you megan for your courage
and leadership
we are all strengthened and inspired by
you
longtime pal jessica mulroney defended
megan against the haters on her
insta story sharing this quote online
abuse
kills people media abuse kills people
just check your right to speak
isn't infringing on someone else's right
to live
there we were witnessing an incredibly
high profile woman
and her husband speaks so openly
courageously honestly
with such dignity about really the
hardest time in their life
and their cry for help hugh jackman also
praised the couple's bravery on twitter
i just want to say thank you megan thank
you harry for your courage
and while many of megan's friends were
quick to give her praise
wendell pierce who played megan's dad on
suits
spoke to britain's lbc talk radio
station on monday
and called the sit-down interview
insignificant given the current
coronavirus pandemic
but when et spoke to the jack ryan star
he clarified his comments
saying that his words were twisted by
the british press
quote my comments were about the
obsession around the royal family and it
shouldn't take priority over the deaths
of the pandemic
i didn't see the interview or know it
was about her suicidal thoughts
i supported megan in the press the year
i lived in london while i was doing
death of a salesman and would
never demean a person's mental health my
words were twisted
a classic tabloid trick